les doigts bien relevé et l'amener après
cet atelier le massage cardiaque n'aura
plus de secret pour eux c'est mort passe
bien participent à la journée
citoyenneté organisée par leurs
professeurs n'avaient pas pour le pour
les massages cardiaques n'avaient pas
besoin peu fallait faire preuve 30
poussée d'air comme ça j'avais pas j'ai
appris plein de choses bas il ya
plusieurs choses que j'avais déjà fait
mais après après le le le truc vous
réanimer une personne j'avais jamais
fait protection civile policiers ou
encore sécurité routière étaient
mobilisés
des ateliers étaient proposés pour
parfois défaire elle les idées reçues
nous sommes dans un atelier de parcours
vélo donc on apprend aux élèves
principalement à s'arrêter au stop
comprendre qu'on s'arrête trois secondes
amstrup le ciel et le passage les vues
qui a un sens giratoire à différents
sens giratoire et un rond point
bon j'ai une bonne connaissance ensemble
et puis il ya l'effet mimétisme avec les
avec les parents les parents dans la
voiture les enfants sont des éponges et
il récupère bien sûr tout ce que les
parents font bien ou mal cent trente
élèves ont été sensibilisés le temps de
cette journée pour que la théorie
apprise à l'école passe à la pratique
à rester en sécurité à responsabilité